[Musique]
et vous envie vous sentez-vous vivent
pleinement vivant moi je vais vous dire
là tout de suite par le fait d'être
devant vous je me sent carrément et
j'aimerais commencer par une citation de
confucius qui dit nous avons de vie et
la deuxième commence quand on se rend
compte qu'on en a qu'une et
effectivement je pense que nous avons
bien de vie la première vient alors de
notre naissance un peu indépendamment de
notre volonté
et puis il ya la deuxième est celle là
on l'a choisi
enfin je crois pas qu'on puisse dire que
l'on choisisse sa vie dans le sens où on
peut choisir des événements sur lesquels
on va intervenir
par contre il ya une chose que j'ai
expérimenté sait qu'on peut choisir sa
façon de la vivre aujourd'hui parce que
je souhaiterais partager avec vous c'est
l'histoire de ma vie mais aussi celle de
ma mort alors pas la mort au sens auquel
vous l'entendez parce que je suis bien
ici présents devant vous mais dans un
sens beaucoup plus profond un sens que
j'ai appris en inde lors d'un voyage en
inde certains sages voit la mort comme
une libération
et c'est même sages considèrent comme
mort des gens qui sont pourtant bien en
vie physiquement et c'est vrai nous
faisons parfois mourir des choses en
nous on peut faire mourir un rêve
en choisissant de ne pas l'écouter on
peut faire mourir l'enfant intérieur
qu'on a et toute la joie qu'ils habitent
en restant trop sérieux on peut faire
mourir une idée en choisissant de ne pas
l'écouter
mais ce qui est magnifique c'est que
nous avons le pouvoir de faire renaître
ces choses là
m'appelle lucmau donné j'ai 20 ans et ça
fait quatre ans que je suis professeur
de kundalini yoga et ce choix est le
résultat d'un long questionnement d'un
long voyage depuis tout jeune je me suis
posé énormément de questions les
questions que l'on se pose tous comment
être plus heureux
comment trouver ma voie comment se
sentir exister livre comment arriver à
m'exprimer en public
malgré le stress et au début de mon
existence par les actes que je faisais
je chercher des réponses à ces questions
là et au début pour me sentir exister
j'avais besoin des autres j'avais besoin
de rendre fiers mes parents mes
professeurs pour me sentir important
j'avais besoin d'avoir la reconnaissance
des autres pour sortir que j'avais de la
valeur j'avais besoin de plaire aux
filles pour me sentir important
et puis dans cette quête de réponses il
ya eu ce voyage en inde un voyage que
j'ai effectués en 2015 un voyage assez
lointain mais pas le plus lointain
lors de ce voyage j'ai rencontré la
pratique du coup d'un délit ni yoga un
peu par hasard
et cette pratique c'était quelque chose
qui a vraiment changé ma vie moi à
l'époque qui voulait me bâtir une image
en fonction des autres
une image de gros dur de mecs fier fort
je me retrouve dans ce court de
kundalini yoga et après quelques
postures quelques exercices de
respiration je me retrouve à pleurer
toutes les larmes de mon corps sans
savoir pourquoi je comprenais pas ce qui
m'arrive et je ressentais des choses que
j'avais encore jamais ressenti jusqu'à
maintenant je ressentais toutes les
blessures qui m'habitait que j'avais
encore jamais osé regarder le lieu de
lutter contre ces pleurs contre tout ce
qui m'habitait j'ai choisi d'accepter et
en acceptant il s'est passé quelque
chose d'encore plus incroyable j'ai
commencé à me libérer
j'ai commencé à ressentir une liberté
une légèreté
j'ai ressenti que cette image que je me
construise est gelée santis détruire
s'envoler pour laisser place à la
personne que j'étais réellement alors
j'ai compris une chose
incroyable c'est que tout ce que je
cherchais à l'extérieur était en fait en
moi c'était que tout l'amour que je
cherchais chez les autres pour me sentir
confiant c'était à moi de me l'a porté
en premier lieu que toute la
reconnaissance que chercher chez les
autres
c'était à moi de me l'apporté c'est moi
le responsable de ma vie c'est -
l'acteur et j'ai compris aussi une
deuxième chose c'est que la force ce
n'est pas de ne pas avoir de faiblesse
de ne jamais pleuré la force c'est
d'accepter d'avoir des faiblesses c'est
comme le fait d'être spirituel beaucoup
de gens pensent que quand on est sur un
chemin
on ne doit pas ressentir de jugement de
désir de jalousie mais être spirituel ce
n'est pas ça c'est accepter ces émotions
là mais ne pas s'identifier comprendre
que l'on est bien plus grand que ça et
donc comment est-ce que ça a marché pour
vous présenter en quelques mots ce
qu'est le yoga et pour vous introduire
sa grande technologie qu'elle connaît
ligne aux gars je citerai your game and
deep singh un grand enseignant il dit
le yoga ce n'est pas à prendre à tenir
debout en équilibre sur une jambe ça ça
s'appelle un à sanaa une posture
le yoga ce n'est pas non plus à prendre
à retenir sa respiration
salah s'appelle le pranayama la science
du souffle le yoga est un état de
conscience et il est sans effort yoga
veut dire union beaucoup pensent que le
yoga est une religion ou alors que c'est
un ensemble d'exercices physiques nous
permettant d'apporter plus de vitalité à
notre corps mais en réalité c'est bien
plus profond que ça le yoga c'est la
relation vous aller entretenir avec vous
même le yoga et le moyen de locomotion
vers un voyage intérieur en vous parce
que le voyage en inde que j'ai effectué
n'a pas été le plus profond le plus
révélateur le voyage le plus profond que
j'ai effectués c'est le voyage en moi
même et donc j'ai continué à pratiquer
le yoga j'ai continué à me libérer à
accepter ce qui m'habitait et à pouvoir
faire des choses parce que le yoga nous
apprend par exemple à travailler sur
notre respiration
car quand on ressent une émotion notre
respiration s'adaptent à cette émotion
là quand on ressent du stress on va
respirer rapidement avoir une
respiration très courte mais si on
apprend à modifier notre respiration on
apprend à modifier nos émotions et donc
à travers de cette pratique j'ai pu me
libérer d'énormément de choses mais j'ai
constaté que les gens autour de moi mes
camarades de classe à l'époque était
confronté aux mêmes problèmes que
j'avais rencontrés auparavant et je
trouvais tellement grave tellement
triste de voir des gens qui avaient des
qualités en eux des dons ne pas oser
réaliser leurs rêves
par peur par doute par timidité je
trouvais trop grave qu'un de mes
camarades ne fasse pas parvenir ses
idées aux autres parce qu'ils n'osaient
pas alors j'ai pris une décision
une autre décision qui a changé ma vie à
l'âge de 16 ans j'ai décidé de devenir
professeur de kundalini yoga
j'allais voir mon directeur et je lui ai
dit je m'absente ray quelques temps j'ai
réussi j'ai obtenu ma formation je suis
une formation et j'ai obtenu mon diplôme
et là il s'est passé quelque chose de
très difficile pour moi
à l'âge de 16 ans j'ai donné mon premier
cours de yoga et là j'ai rencontré des
doutes énorme
les gens m'attendaient et je me suis dit
attends mais quelle légitimité toi tu as
un gamin de 16 ans allait enseigner à
des gens qui ont trois à quatre fois ton
vécu tu es qui toi pour faire ça quelle
légitimité
vous voyez cette question là cette
question elle aurait pu tuer la personne
que je suis devant vous cette question
elle aurait pu tuer leurs rêves et
l'appel que j'avais en moi et cette
question de légitimité
peu importe qui on est peu importe ce
qu'on fait on la ressentir à tous un
moment dans notre vie moi c'était mon
jeune âge
mais demain on peut se dire mais je suis
bien trop vieux pour faire cette
activité là où j'ai pas les compétences
requises pour faire et atteindre cet
objectif
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut dépasser
ces questions de légitimité
comment est ce que j'ai fait pour les
dépasser eh bien j'aimerais vous
l'illustré en vous racontant une
histoire qui m'a profondément touché et
inspiré c'est une histoire amérindienne
d'une grand mère qui parle avec sa fille
qui lui dit tu sais ma fille j'ai en moi
deux loups de loups qui n'arrête pas de
se battre
qui sont ces deux loups lui demande la
petite fille est bien le premier c'est
le loup du mal le coup de la colère de
la peur du doute et le deuxième qui est
il le deuxième loup c'est le loup du
bien c'est le lieu de notre coeur le
loup des rêves de la confiance mais
alors lequel de ces deux loups gagne
alors la grand-mère lui répond celui que
tu nourris
nous avons tous en nous c'est de peu
importe ce que nous allons faire nous
allons tous à un moment donné ressentir
du doute ressentir de la peur mais
qu'est ce que nous choisissons de nous
rire qu'elle loue allons nous nourrir
parce que nos rêves sont en réalité bien
plus grand
ce petit sentiment de peur parce que
nous sommes en réalité bien plus grand
que ses sentiments là parce que écouter
ses rêves ses s'écouter soi même
réaliser ses rêves ses se réaliser soi
même et peu importe si on atteint ou pas
ces objectifs ou ses rêves ce n'est pas
ça qui compte
ce qui compte c'est de s'écouter ce qui
compte c'est de se rencontrer et de
prendre conscience de la belle personne
que l'on n'est pas ce que la confiance
ce n'est pas l'absence de doute la
confiance c'est nourrir l'appel de notre
coeur notre intention
plutôt que tout ce qui nous en dissuader
nous avons tous en nous la capacité la
possibilité de trouver cette relation
avec nous même de réaliser la personne
que nous sommes et pour ce faire
j'aimerais vous inviter tous ensemble ce
soir à faire un exercice de yoga et je
vais vous inviter à fermer les yeux et
vous allez commencer à respirer
uniquement par le nez essayez de prendre
des inspirations les plus profondes les
plus longue possible et des expirations
aussi profonde et aussi longue et
concentrez-vous uniquement sur ce qui se
passe en vous prenez conscience de vos
pieds sur le sol de votre poids sur la
chaise sur laquelle vous êtes assis
concentrez-vous sur le bruit de la
respiration sur vos inspirations sur vos
expiration
relâchez vos épaules votre visage et
petit à petit essayez de complètement
plongé en vous et essayez par ce voyage
que vous êtes en train de faire de
chercher toutes les qualités qui vous
habite toute la beauté qui vous habite
essayer de vous connecter à cette
lumière qui est en vous essayez de vous
connecter à la belle personne que vous
êtes
j'ai vous demandez prendre une grande
inspiration de garder l'air de bien
rester connectés à cette belle personne
que vous êtes et je vais vous demander
s'il vous plaît de faire vivre cette
personne-là expiré et merci à tous
[Musique]